just keep popping in and out fourth
time's the charm
lost a bunch of subscribers doing this
yeah people hate us now people don't
like us sure we'll be hearing about this
every social network soon enough no ends
even a year that's that hey who's the
one person who's here okay we're gonna
get this don't worry so real we've never
never happened before I'm not sure why
usually it just takes two tries
yeah man this better work I'm right
there with you well give it three
minutes and then we'll hop into it we'll
give it three more tries I don't know
why this is doing this it's very
frustrating for me Kermit a very
friendly guys guys how's everyone doing
this is so embarrassing are they're very
embarrassed embarrassed a little bummed
out because you just figured out how to
use the actual camera and it keeps the
keeps on logging us and I don't know why
I keep doing that
losing video very upsetting stuff guys
very upsetting stuff hello to all of you
David Aaron Gabriel Roland I I think I
think this is working this time doesn't
even have a photo of us this is YouTube
Zen is it is yeah this is not somehow I
think their livestream thing is just
janky yeah
it's saying that we are not receiving
their day a fast enough rate we're weird
that's so strange because yeah this
isn't this ain't us but we'll try our
best can you guys currently hear us okay
David it's it's even cooler talking with
you man can you guys hear us all right
we did a speed test on the internet and
it said it was fine yeah Oh Jamal
Morehouse's balls are tight
ours too buddy no right no I can't hear
you okay you got us you got us
all right good I'm Joe edge of Jones 51
people in here man this is great
this is so exciting we're just want to
count how many people come in 55 and all
right looks like the live stream is at
least working because it's saying that
skinning I got back okay now I'd say
it's good the health is good
okay saying now the stream is finally
good I don't know we're asked there's
Jesus Christ it's hard about that guys
how is everyone let's start with that
and then we're gonna talk about some
things we're gonna we're gonna check out
this trailer for good boys it's
universal and you know so this videos
not going to be monetized this is just a
fun livestream to do with all you cool
cats over here so yeah how's it all
Monday going what's everybody up to you
guys work yeah asking what's there yeah
some people are different time zones for
everyone here man
oh snap it is spring break we gotta do
some debauchery let's take some shots do
a line of cocaine off each other some
bucco cane off of John's butthole yeah
whoo all right fresh from Collider you
know colliders overrated
fresh from can't be I'm going to tell
them that when I'm there the
free-for-all
like guys what are we doing here this is
matter there here we go now it's super
bright for you guys oh yeah okay it
wouldn't be a real rejects I've seen
without a readjustment to the video all
right here we go guys look let's just
pull up the trailer for good boys we're
just gonna get into this all right
get this out of the way some people are
asking for it
yeah Nora normally I would be bummed to
be rushed but I'm a little nervous
myself I don't know how to do that we
don't know how to work the was OBS or
something where you show what's going on
on the smear were looking at hey Matt
beer after you thanks so much dude
or your awesome super chat skills right
there
methyl beer that is about what John
Campea makes per livestream those two
bucks right there oh so appreciate they
really add up in a month and actually
because this is universal it's gonna get
deep monetize with the audio in here oh
yeah or it's actually worth our time now
you're splitting that Bucky appreciate
that Mike so here you guys should go
check out his channel all right we're
gonna watch this trailer you'll have the
audio in the background so you guys know
where we're at let's get to it now shall
we oh yeah we're doing everything wrong
and back that's all back it's Monday you
know I and you guys can watch the
trailer
[Laughter]
[Music]
because I'm not a [ __ ] child this is
how we draw my god there's Molly
[Music]
[Music]
funny kids look at pornography oh we got
stories we go at first it does seem a
little gimmicky yeah a young kid wearing
with each other but then I remember what
I really started dropping like you know
f-bombs all the time that was first
grade start with two things on a brother
jab Iike a bad influence a like if you
don't tell on me when I swear I won't
telling you and you swear I was in first
grade so that I went to the playground
the next day I talked to a guy and hated
Tyson and I said the same exact thing to
him so we started looking at people
being like that [ __ ] football [ __ ]
just started swearing all the time so
yeah I I do I relate with that element
this looks fun this looks like looks
like what drillbit Taylor should have
been with a hint of Superbad yeah yeah
it's actually a really good way to
describe that yeah I am curious
Superbad and I'm generally a fan of Seth
Rogen and them I
I don't know seems to me this trailer
kind of was fighting that line where I'm
like this looks like it could just be
this one gimmick but it also looks like
maybe it wants to have a plot like I
don't know the whole thing where they
steal the backpack in the Molly I was
like oh maybe that's the plot but i
couldnt really tell what the plot was
other than these three kids hanging out
and swearing what they're saying on the
gimmick that there are little kids who
are sparing yeah you know what do you
see in movies like it and stuff but
they're doubling down and the Rocchi cut
seth rogen comedy territory yeah bridge
looks funny yeah I'm not like over the
moon about it but I can imagine maybe
laughing at what ages you guys start
cursing at and what was your first curse
word yeah they should have just not had
him food so was every we're just talking
about Captain Marvel you eaten god I
actually pretty much I'm so sick of the
dam does anyone else think of talking
about Captain Marvel yet it's been it's
been a whole week of Captain Marvel and
no one's really even talking about the
movie Captain Marvel I know
gosh geez what's happening is we're
talking about the movie good boys and
then no one seems interested at all I'm
talking what do you guys think about
these good boys honestly I thought the
intro was the funniest progress okay the
intro was the funniest part of that yeah
it Seth Rogen's I had an unfortunate but
you know he has to sell the movie has
their you know could trick people into
thinking he might play a part in it yeah
and then he directed into this by over
yeah that's true hey t Jack you so much
man III appreciate Norway checking out
her reviews I'm really trying to tap
into the Norway market more master bird
Gregory actually saw fighting with my
family this past weekend oh I thought
you were saying he said that about me
yeah I didn't see fighting with my
family I highly recommend you guys go
check that out as soon as possible
hey okay finally some people are
actually talking about the damn trailer
yeah it looks funny Iran I'm not like
like oh I can't wait to go see this
movie but you know it looks like
passable funny entertainment yeah
doesn't look particularly clever or
special to me yet but yeah it looks like
it has the full potential to at least be
wild and amusing yeah you know so guys
do you think Captain Marvel is gonna
make a billion dollars at the box office
it's like how do we ask a question and
we just wait usually Quietus on the live
stream here most likely some knope's
definitely x' man now yes yes most
definitely
yeah maybe 100 billion doubt it
[ __ ] no from sapa garcia
worst MC know you'd okay oh here it
comes
in I think I think it's gonna make a
billion dollars before Shazam comes out
hey yeah it's definitely yeah I hope it
makes it really and yeah right now it's
already made money in China it's gonna
be it's gonna make more money in China
this Chinese people are gonna eat that
[ __ ] up there's one thing Chinese people
love it's American feminine Thomas
Atkins says Greg is just getting hotter
thanks man dude you do just good I I try
I try
you know I go to the gym and I just look
at myself in the mirror naked all the
other guys are like dude stop
masturbating in front of the mirror it's
a locker room not your bedroom but it's
such an effective workout on you that's
primarily what I do to gain muscles in
the area there touch myself then touch
myself touch myself this livestream
sucks
you're telling me man you're telling me
John gets hotter too yeah Jonas on will
remain the same kind of hot forever yeah
stagnant hot and gave trailer I'm pretty
sure John is the hotter one dude
everyone already tells me that all the
time and then my girlfriend Liz it out
to me all the time
what's the secret of my hairdo oh I used
the Sebastian conditioner that stuff
really helps in division but most days
it's really hard to make it actually
function the way I wanted to
most days my hair is really hard but no
matter what name you have Greg you're an
idol to all of us thanks G oh that's
really sweet Ian man I don't know
be an inspiration and I don't I don't
feel like I've done enough to really
contribute that level of respect but you
know what I'll take it either way you're
just getting going
Brit Marling we're just really
appreciate that Brittany thank you so
much you ever come out with your own
merch one day bleep red shirt com flash
the real rejects we never promote it and
we rarely wear our own clothes but we
certainly have it thanks so much
Brittany thanks really sweetie I can go
grab an example if you like ah yeah
Brittany you look hot too laying I love
that last name ever since Lana Lang from
the CW show or clubber Lang from that
Rocky movie dude Roman M you got to
watch that video the aqus on honest
interview with Greg album that's one of
my favorite sketches we've ever done so
much fun Carl of Troy wants to know
what's the deal with Aleta vs Captain
Marvel well apparently one does not push
feminism in your face and the other one
does according to people who I don't
associate with the different there goes
a Salazar never said anything about what
kind of critics watch the movie and
there you go Greg you look like an Arab
I'll have you know I was once a short
film for UCLA called SAR cells where I
played an Arab boy mm-hmm
beat up a Jew in it it was not me making
a joke that was the part of the film but
then I had a turning point where I
realized maybe be enough that you made
such a good idea
a little not enough for you very intense
fifteen-year-old Greg got a lot of
emotions do you want the x-men in the
MCU yes yes I do
as soon as possible what about you John
eventually sure that's this John with
the feedback right there yes I would
like oh yeah we've actually talked a lot
about how this could work in an
interesting way and it's anything like
what we've been discussing I think it
could actually be pretty cool I'm
planning on doing a video where I came
up with an idea of how it could be
infused into the MCU I really really
thought about it and
well I want to release it before endgame
comes out because ya guys can you say
wrong gear added reg reg this but it's
an Eastern Isle not about that means
Greg do you visit Asia monthly I make I
make a monthly trip to Asia the entire
surrounding area spread STDs everywhere
I go and I'm pregnant at least one woman
at a time there's gonna be multiple of
those agent Greg's before you know it
and even more Asian than real Greg hey
the artist Steven thanks man if you need
any artists for merchant stuff I mean hi
there I will draw pointy nips pointing
nips are the things that sell these days
all the Instagram people I follow have
pointy nips pointy tips and if this is
if this is any indication of you super
chatting us five big ones here you would
pay us to do the designs and we would
keep all the profit so thanks the artist
Steven G but he got a youtube channel
here or something buddy that's really
cool
Agustin is acquired which is the movie
that most want to see in this year I
really want to see the movie us I've
heard so many great things about it and
and yeah hey you know I need my top hang
it would def be the top Heiser hang out
you should have waited a super chance
buddy yeah I would say I just did a
whole thing about it on the John Campea
show John what are your other your
feelings I wait you know you did the
trailer reaction yeah you already know
and our subscribers the hundred
something people who are here right now
did not really get an opportunity for me
to get my two cents on it because that's
about as many views as or reactions get
a hundred eighty views right yeah I am
watching the reviews or looking at the
reviews for it I'm loving that
everyone's coming back with the
affirmation of how weird the movie is
and how strange it's turning out to be
it seems like a movie that who would be
a critical darling I am kind of curious
to see how audiences will respond to it
because based off of what the reviews
are saying I'm having the impression
that I'll have one of those endings were
like what the [ __ ] was this movie really
all about
I'm confused so I wonder if audiences
will click with it the same way people
have clicked with the movie get out
because this one seems like Jordan Peele
he's got all the ring that he's able to
do whatever the hell he wants with this
movie so you know usually in a case like
that he gets something that's a lot more
nuanced was done found a video of you at
use you found my video and you sauna
guys do you want to sell vitamins and
that's not as that was in the script
guys if you're looking for great Olympic
athlete supplements join USANA or rx
health company I can't take sides my
friends are on artx would you like to
join our seminar recruit it's fun man
it's really fun Thomas Adkins been
watching forever brother Thomas what is
your favorite video from the real
rejects put it down I'm keeping a look
at all these comments appreciate the
super chat they're really your fandom
the first person who gives us $10,000 in
the super chat we will retire yeah yeah
I don't think it's gonna be like another
hereditary I I think that it might be
shades of response that hereditary guy
you know what I mean
- bum oh no for yeah for us not not us
you and I oh we get ready response all
the time yeah Bob Marley says John
Krasinski is Reed Richards that would be
a great choice yeah yeah come with
people calling for him and Emily Blunt
to be Devin sue storm
oh really quick before while we got this
live stream going but do you want to say
happy birthday to the man named David
Gandy Andy he's no more a top eight
restore a long time he's a dear dear
friend of ours and I know he's not
watching now because of you know mrs.
birthday he's got better things to do so
David happy birthday I love you buddy
hopefully got my message
let's see here why did you guys take
down the reaction for good boys we did
and we did it at the beginning of this
livestream now we've just been having
trouble with the other livestream which
is maybe what you saw Jenna Randolph
woman
my hot lady ahaha that's a woman hold of
attractive nature I just messaged you
back on patreon my dear I'm sorry that
the thing with your did with the dog
Kelly did not work out she she got a dog
that she had to return it the dog was
like who Jose killing all her neighbors
surrounding and putting it down and just
put it back in the pan without saying I
know Jenna it's her birthday next week
so expect a proper shout out to go
forward really appreciate that my dears
it's gonna turn 28 that means she's
legal guys whoo no hit her up or girls I
haven't asked her what her sexuality is
you know orientation I know she's a
woman feel free to comment
Grandal MP love your video guys your
reviews are always excellent I don't
agree with most of what brie Larson -
said recently if I don't to see Captain
Marvel Wednesday
did you read everything brie Larson said
we did a whole video on it you know I'm
not gonna talk about any of that
I'm so sick of it but watch our video of
our reaction to the hate comments
everything that we have to say anything
is always out on our video angel Lopez
says nobody cares about you - yet he's
here oh thanks buddy thank you for
reminding us way to show you don't care
bye bye giving a click on our life I am
taking time and effort out to spend time
on us that makes a lot of sense makes so
much sense somebody from Switzerland
longtime fan are you ever going back I
would love to go back to Switzerland man
dude the guys that are hot so everyone
stays in shape impossibly hot gen or gen
Hornet ran no I haven't seen the house
that Jack built yet but yeah I would
like to I think Lars von Trier is the
best film maker in the world he never
makes boring films did you see Tyrone's
review of Captain Marvel
Tyrone actually sent me a message I'm
gonna play it for you guys it was pretty
funny to me of how it all went this is a
message from Tyra this is worth the
livestream in and of itself for you guys
to hear this okay cross over this this
is right before he went live talking
about
how he was losing subscribers on Captain
Marvel review holy [ __ ] I'm looking at
my video that I just made and notice
that you made a video talking about they
hate comments you were getting for
Captain Marvel
oh my god I gotta watch this you guys
hear that you guys hear that entire we
got one view at least from Tyrone Meg
look Tyrone said that and then I texted
him back going we got two separate
reasons it sounds like you got it
because you didn't like it I got hate
because I recommended it and he said lol
yeah
Oh Britney Britney why don't you just
wire and just just get just send us your
bank account information it's why are
any of your earnings drink strictly to
my Wells Fargo account yeah thanks
frightening what are your thoughts on
the pewdiepie versus t series this is
the thing with super chats I always feel
pressure to be like I gotta give such a
great answer and then where I don't know
what they're talking about I'm like oh I
feel like I'm wasting your time uh
educate me a little bit on their
pewdiepie versus teachers you know what
is what is happening even with all the
you know
Nazi jokes and him saying the n-word
PewDiePie's not a racist guys haha I
don't know who is beefing with now all
I've heard about pewdiepie recently is
that we oughta watch his YouTube rewind
Jenna Randolph I actually regret taking
Kelly back or they don't like your
document from the same place it's too
quiet letter it quite a lot this oh I'm
sorry
here I know a lot of people have had a
hard week end I'm gonna go into all
their personal reasons why my buddy open
up its therapy our I'm sorry about that
Jenna I know but it's you know I was
when I was a kid I had a kitty and then
about a week in owning the cat
something happened in the backyard is an
outdoor cat and then it like it died
about a week and a having it so I know
what it's like to have a pet feel like
you got a new family member then lose it
so early on and I'm really sorry about
that but hopefully down the road I mean
I feel like in your situation because of
time and stuff it's better to get a it's
better to get a cat for your situation
like for me as like I feel like I have
to really attend to a dog right now
so yeah Greg looks jacked thanks dude
only there the rest is all flab but the
arms pecs are going yeah say you can do
dance the dance it's taco sauce correct
how many times day to your nipples get
hard have you ever counted three
whenever I whenever I'm working out and
III think about the no man's land scene
and Wonder Woman tears and nipple chills
simultaneously as I'm working out every
single time pursuit of happiness the
clickbait is about the fact that we had
to start this live stream like four
times see ya the interstellar trailer
hell yeah oh dude those were those were
the day back in the DIA oh dude here's
15% off for one of your Godzilla Deema I
appreciate that
we are AMC a-list members so we wouldn't
you don't have to pay extra but
definitely but it'll I that to the month
of the a-list right will apply it to
every five dollar parking charge yeah
thanks to its really appreciate it
God we will be your friend Jenna it's
really quiet yeah I didn't get an older
dog little later on Jenna don't you
worry about it okay Robert Kevin just
see both Captain Marvel and Aleta and
then make up your own mind cuz they both
deserve your support but you can only
like one yeah you can't like more than
one can light and if you if you like
both you gotta like Aleta more claimant
well it's objectively plain on plain and
simple
hey right you just watch around the
campus thanks but I really appreciate
that's a different kind of setup and I
didn't notice when I was looking back
the friends I'm like I'm not really
making eye contact with the audience
here so next time I'm on there I gotta
do a better job all-time favorite TV
show that's easy as [ __ ] for me friends
Breaking Bad those two no no prom that's
the one Jen horrid Rand
I love the gorillas yes I love your
views on the Captain Marvel video on
Captain Marvel oh thanks buddy
much you're pretty good guys you gotta
go check out my job to be episode I'm a
lot sharper there I had time to prep
some research here you know we're just
going off of what you guys are saying Oh
off somebody else wants to know if
you're related to just get although
what's the answer
yeah she's my wife and my sister and
she's gonna get in a lot of trouble now
haha I have not played Devil May Cry 5
but it's out now and I'm so excited to
get my friggin hands on a machine that
can play it and then together the
hardest said friends was mindless
wisecracking
who the [ __ ] do you think you are
talking to me like that you're allowed
to have your opinion but you're wrong
but but but keep having it Michael
Burnett oh dude he's the son of fire
burn every fire Michael Burnett thanks
buddy
yeah you know you don't have to reflects
or patron anymore no ever I mean that
that comp thanks you thank you so much
do Qixing gamers hate John Campea Oh
zeroing out I gotta go bye guys these
two are the cutest you too thank you so
much thank you John's pregnant I don't
know this we're gonna start mines
pregnant yeah we're gonna start one
those channels where we raise our kids
in front of you and then get them taken
away when we do something messed up oh
that's so awesome
we great watch thanks Tim Morrison I am
friends with Brandi price she's uh she
she lives in Texas now though so I don't
ever see her she hasn't been back here
but you know every once in a while we'll
catch up
Thank You Vincent you know Vincent
you're the one who's awesome what is
this geeks [ __ ] Vincent that's my dad's
middle name
so I like you a lot
and UN is my maiden name so appreciate
that geeks and gamers equals Fox News or
Star Wars and Marvel content
what's my thoughts on them there exist
Matthew leaks is funny Greg you and your
brother look nothing alike who's
better-looking who I don't want to hear
the comment I just want to see ya Jake
Gyllenhaal Ryan Gosling your arrogance
man that's a great question yes they are
a lizard um David loved your dude I love
you to you David you're so handsome and
beautiful I would love to have a baby
with you
yeah especially in your profile pic here
Roman and Greg and John equals Grande
Java Java that is our warrior well uh
Scarlett protect on tight and I do this
stream along store that our patreon so I
do I review every single episode after
I'm done April is kind of presenting
itself to be a crazy busy month for a
lot of shows I mean one punch man is
coming back
attack on Titan Game of Thrones there's
so much happening and there's a few
shows that are patient where we do
reaction highlights for them if I have
the time I will do it because it takes
about a little cool like I've got a good
at doing it under an hour to do the
reaction highlights for them but
hopefully I'll have enough time to do
that Taylor Taylor thanks buddy
you know doesn't matter if you super
chet a dollar or a hundred I will treat
you based off the amount that you have
super chatted of how much I love you so
right now I just like you dollars worth
a lot
Darkseid's st. 2700 cap Marvel do at the
box office next weekend it'll have legs
I'll have legs Marvel yeah I think I
think it'll probably have about a 50 to
60 percent drop just because the word of
mouth you know has an a CinemaScore it
doesn't seem like the word of mouth has
been like you've gotta watch this but I
think it went if when endgame has a
second trailer I imagine they'll
probably throw cat marble in there which
will probably get more people to go out
to go watch it
oh I think I got a seat this is Captain
marbles an endgame yeah I think that's
gonna make a difference it'll be a smart
move geeks and gamers Matt beer thanks
but it got big for Star Wars hate videos
oh they a channel okay
that would make sense I guess that's
cool I mean I don't want to become a
channel that thrives off of hey I mean
there are channels that do that's their
thing is they hate and they you know
people like them and then if that's them
good for them and I don't want us to be
that thanks to Captain Marvel I have
discovered who a lot of those channels
about I would rather be a channel that
it only likes everything and then when
you don't we don't like something we are
hated for it Bohemian Rhapsody yeah
glass even just being mildly taken aback
the Green Book won that Oscar display
that's both enjoying it yeah well I said
I really like the daredevil season 3 but
I had issues with it all man people
thought I did but you know we like
everything that's how that's how people
respond to us we like every we like
everything but however I am over
critical of everything unless it is
captain one yes Jenna rendalf I love you
guys you help cheer me Jenna Jenna Jenna
watch your bank account
don't be homeless on our account I think
we had the weirdest relationship with
super shots I see other you specially
going I can't be a show or like super
super today like all dolls every
freaking new comment but for us we're
going to be a strange dynamic with it
yeah Taylor Taylor do you love me now
well since you doubled what you put
before yeah that's how you earn Greg's
love every love for me is a transaction
okay yeah it's not unconditional it's
very conditional red Vil go back to the
beginning of this stream and we watched
the trailer yeah Michael Burnett ooh
controversial comment let's get it on
Michael B's comment here b4 [ __ ] he's
saying what ww-was on Wonder Woman not
World War Wonder Woman was honestly more
in-your-face than Captain Marvel Wow
in what respect I think he's talking
about the femme
is a man go out man look out I mean this
would be an interesting argument to have
I guess well uh I guess there's only
really there's that one point where
they're like things are different on
earth and you know when you step inside
Congress or well they did a lot of
Harlem ins yeah I think I think Wonder
Woman had the ability to talk more
directly about it because of the time
period that were in where it was way
more established on the separation and
then you got a man going on Amazonian
land you know what I mean so that's I
think that's why you could get away with
it more but like we said before just
because there's feminism in it does not
mean I'm bothers us as watcher that one
video well I'm like I don't know anytime
you watch something that has like a well
diverse representational cast or
something you're witnessing feminism
happen like anytime I see a narrative
that involves a strong female character
who doesn't have their strength bestowed
upon them by a dude or something like
that like you're witnessing it happy as
you've probably seen I think it's funny
that people freaked so much about
feminism because I'm sure that there's a
lot in your viewing that incorporates
those ideals that you're just not aware
of the Kill Bill have feminism issues
when it came out cuz I'm like there's
the leads a woman she used to of the
biggest showdowns are with women even
even it with our each either one girl
with the spinning oh yeah well the nice
thing about her [ __ ] name was well
she's or like a lot of women ended up I
don't wanna call on Rome be like Fritz
from Rome but then again the internet
wasn't so internet and it wasn't in the
main focus of the conversation Britney
Lange you two have a great night that's
a big super challenge dog you get hotter
by the minute
see that's how you get hot you increase
the super chance money is directly
correlated to attractiveness that's why
I like plastic surgery is so effective
because you're literally paying for
beauty it always works watch you guys
next time you have internalized saying
keep up with the great work by the way
come to Canada for a visit life does not
get too busy I want to go to me we have
so many
subscribers and just Canadian friends
Canada just seems so low as a matter of
fact the reason we were able to get a
computer up there was someone a patient
from Canada helped us have a big time
with that so really doing Britney thank
you see it's it's that's why the super
chats are big on her and she's Canadian
no kindness to shows along does live
there alright Michael B's got to write
here
Wonder Woman was still better overall
though feminism isn't bad don't at me I
hope you all go attack on me one media
as soon as possible
for all the feminism he's in support of
good it's good
Taylor Taylor Taylor that's true FEM P
my mouth movie is good it's good plain
and simple got a good hand Blaine and
cinahl guys love from the Philippines
that's where yeah right over here if you
saw my DNA test from 70% Filipino my
whole life I thought I was a solid 50/50
come to find out my DNA says otherwise
and I white but I'm not defined by my
DNA
I'm defined by being an American Trump
so I was just imagining like a flag
flowing behind your head and an eagle
crying out y'all stoned not at 12:45 in
the afternoon my alright we're still
very very sober I I have gotten high act
like this hour but there's a time where
I used to man I don't like it I really
don't wait whatever people are like you
know they do like 5:00 a.m.
reactionary people go you guys are high
like I'm not it's just 5:00 a.m. like
this my eyes are red this is the first
hour of the morning where it really
feels like it's today and not just
really late last rise oh dude
hey Taylor's all the way from Australia
thanks to Oh dawn do your Australian say
his name hi Tyler Tyler also want to say
hello from Australia love y'all that's
my cartoonish accent of your people
Hey Ankush we did I read all the early
reviews versus and I'm super excited for
very mostly trying to come up with a
funny opening to do for it also I did
read that comic so I I'm kind of prep
myself for a little compare do you guys
think there'll be a Black Adam tease at
the end of Shazam for fans of Shazam do
you think they'll be able I think there
will at least be at minimum if the rock
is not in it I think at minimum there
will be the tomb of Black Adam that
appears at the end of the movie oh hey
Michael the collector 98 happy 21st
birthday shout out to you I hope that
you [ __ ] up right now okay yeah across
the stars I have sad news every once in
a while I do watch TV spots on my own
and certain trailers without reacting to
it on camera and I already did I already
did
watch those TV spots they look great
wouldn't have been able to had anything
new tour videos though honestly you know
like the only things that we're really
do or I can't really add commentary tend
to be those Family Guy try not to last
but even then we add some commentary
with the guest so most the time with the
movie related stuff I'm trying to do her
best everyone someone we find ourselves
a situation where it's hard to add
commentary but that's why we don't react
to every single TV spot anymore now
because after wire I should say the
almonds we gonna see you guys back in
the Schmo down at all when are we gonna
be there Johnny you're gonna be at the
free-throw live at the El Portal Theatre
at North Hollywood be sure to go check
us out there guys get out I reckon
Captain Marvel will show up and Suzanne
will Shazam is Captain Marvel isn't that
my gout oh yeah I make film says I want
to know if you guys think movies try too
hard to be diverse instead of focusing
on character and story it did play me
mother what do you mean you see like an
Asian guy a black guy in a movie you're
like yeah their focus too much on
diversity are you talking about trying
to do too much in one film or are you
trying to say like they're taking a
message or just hitting it way too hard
on the nose
we're gonna get out here I think if I
see too many ethnicities it's in my face
and I don't like it it's just like eight
white people in one Asian that's fine
yeah I mean yeah I guess I'll notice
some way I just started watching the
haunting of Hill House and that has a
very diverse cast and partway through
like the second episode or something I
just noticed oh they think it's a lot of
different actors cool you know it's so
like I didn't feel like that was super
in my face but I noticed it raised misra
says none of my comments to read it's
cool though
alright where's art and I just found Oh
Matthew leach says James Cameron said
Arnold in this new Terminator no he'll
be bad again like it was the original
thought you know it's you know it's
randomly thinking about when I was I was
in the car today I think about that
moment in Terminator the first one when
Arnold first gets the sunglasses and
it's got the total like really like
that's when that music sound like a
horror movie
slowly puts them on like a robot finding
his full identity so yeah I'd be really
excited to see him be bad again I want
to see him be morally ambiguous alright
guys just a few more questions they're
going to call this a day okay for reals
hey getting a lot of love for your
double ptosis shirt John Oh hells yeah
god I got across fandoms right there
double toasty grill is all about it do
you think
MGK would come back and having him again
know anything you should wait like
another year before he did yeah I don't
think he should
I think he's gonna get destroyed he's
acting now what is it what does he need
to do that for why don't you Gus do my
live gaming any live gaming I think that
would be really fun there's just you
know because we want to be up-to-date
and I'd be like what's a live stir I
would wind up live streaming a
random-ass video I want a live stream
like I wouldn't be damned I wouldn't
want to do like live streaming for for
like adventure games like God a war Red
Dead Eye I would have liked a live
stream like mercy game's battle shooting
games like that would be a lot of fun
like you get a guest on for that he is
do Tong and [ __ ] to each other that
would be pretty fun that way I mean I
would personally just be down to street
like a resident
to remake or something looks like kind
of spooky and stuff the tie rods are
beyond cats and marbled backlash
thoughts no got no thoughts if anything
were the minority on YouTube it's out
titled his opinion as are we it's
allowed to think what he wants
thanks Andrew Hayes you got a sick mind
who get the last of your speedram
questions in here guys Greg is living
here we're about to click off what I'm
nowhere near the better singer I learned
how to I learned how to pass on rock
band because of John oh happy birthday
urvich kanya can I get birthday Lisa
Johnson he wants you to sing a song what
song Bohemian Rhapsody that's definitely
in my vocal range
[Music]
rest in peace to your comment David
Constance a second yeah Ronnie's talking
about a sly 72 oh yeah yeah yeah he's
gonna play Rambo five at the White House
you know Rambo five is gonna be called
first blood pressure weight as can take
place at the White House
no it's gonna be is screening it at the
White House really his friends would
drop oh oh okay
interesting or I feel so many things
these friends would trumpety Trump Trump
I don't know how to feel right now
hey man everyone's inside to their own
political views someone am i doing them
a you Basu Minami human Oh any advice to
ask a girl out she's a Disney fan like
me ooh watch charisma on command
yeah I think you give you so much better
advice watch to respond good man John
and I don't know how to ask girls out I
wait so we're like oh we're making out I
guess where I have a chance of seeing
each other I only got a chance to see
Romney play Freddie but I the Bohemian
Rhapsody made me wish for the Sacha
Baron Cohen version Oh
commercial point of view I know okay
I know Game of Thrones before endgame is
gonna be nuts right David David David
listen John doesn't watch attack on
Titan I would like to start there I do
stream along as our patreon for it okay
and our stream along reward tier is
cheaper than everyone else who does it
so yeah that's fine I will be watching
John should have played Freddie Mercury
all right guys well we're gonna log off
right now I want to thank you guys for
being patient and doing around for with
us we took this four times to get this
live stream working I don't know why the
connection was so bad but thank you to
all who have a really quick shout outs
where's that page that we had here of
all the people who contributed to the
super chats today it's right here I have
it John don't you worry Matt beer
Brittany Lane are Stephan zeroing out
Thomas Atkins Jenna Randolph David
Constantine II Asst Michael Burnett
Taylor Taylor several times I think I
repeated some of your names
thank you guys y'all are so sweet much
love to everyone here we'll see you guys
soon expect regular uploads this week
and hopefully we can get the better
quality camera working for these live
streams not sure why I did that
we'll see you guys soon peace